[Music]
if I put on my pure scientist hat as
opposed to my American scientist hat
pure scientist hat I say if we're if we
don't build the lab somebody else will
and the science will get discovered if
we don't explore the moon somebody else
will it will get discovered that's one
of the hallmarks of science that
distinguishes it from art in science if
you don't do it somebody else will
whereas an art if Beethoven didn't
compose the Ninth Symphony no one else
before or after is going to compose the
ninth symphony that he composed no one
else is going to paint
starry night by Van Gogh so so science
when done properly is never owned by one
nation or another so that's what
happened with particle physics in
America we were building the largest
super collider there ever was the
superconducting supercollider
to be based in Texas 200 miles
circumference ring we would accelerate
particles smashed them and explore the
conditions that were that were common in
the early universe that budget got
cancelled by Congress as we were winding
down out of the Cold War so no longer
was that physicist the darling of the
sciences the way they were after the
Second World War
going into the Cold War because it was
the it was the innovations of physicists
that created the bomb in the Manhattan
Project physics basically ended the war
so without a war certainly without a
Cold War there was a question as to what
the value of the supercollider was to
the nation now I don't know how many
people you'd get to admit that fact but
my read of history is that when nations
spend huge amounts of money on things
it's hardly ever for the pure value of
exploration there's usually secondary
motives primary motives that are
presented secondarily like military like
economics or some other sort of factor
that matters to national security so so
happen Europe took up the task so at
CERN which is the acronym for the super
collider the european consortium super
collider in switzerland they now have
the most powerful collider in the world
and their other ones going to are going
to be probing the conditions near the
big bang not us
so my pure scientists had is i don't
care who does it as long as it's done
long as somebody does it the american
scientist in me i'm born and raised in
america and i care deeply for this
nation is i kind of prefer that we did
it because i know we can if we weren't
wealthy or if we had a i'd say you know
there's now's not the time let some
other wealthier more powerful nation do
it than us but that is it time for me to
say that or we really that poor or we
really that without means of a three
trillion dollar budget to spend it's
about the balance of that portfolio of
spending that makes a nation how much do
you spend on art health care poverty
research and development the veterans
military you lay out the portfolio that
is the country that you live in and
three trillion is enough to buy far as
i'm concerned anything we want anything
we choose to and so I wish it were here
because if we'd make it here the
opportunities arise here the engineering
opportunities the engineering solutions
to problems we'd never seen before that
then created a climate and a landscape
of innovation that I remember I remember
growing up America had like the longest
bridge the longest tunnel the fastest
planes and for a while there I thought
well that's just bragging rights what
are you doing and then I realize in
order to create the extremes of these
technologies you have to innovate you
can't just step there it's not it's
hardly ever just make it a little longer
this well it's longer so it's more
stress on the structure there's so we
have to invent something new to
accommodate this need or this desire and
therein are the seeds of innovation
[Music]